rest
makes it EAS for me
see
t
that
get
seats
okay that's fine he going to do it
that's
fine
seats I'm going
yeah
ter
[Music]
for
that's getting to
look that beard is beginning to look
very
just
[Music]
hope
that
might
[Music]
come
are
ask
I
the house will come to order the chair
recognizes a member from Auburn
representative Osborne who moves at the
house Jour from the session of January
4th 2024 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it the house is
adjourned the house will attend to a
Prayer by house chaplain Reverend Bob
Stu Stewart pastor of St Paul's United
Manchester good morning New Hampshire
House of
Representatives good morning Mr
Speaker let us prepare our hearts for
prayer let us be still for a moment to
Center our thoughts on God and on the
day
ahead good morning
God it is with gratitude that we thank
you for this day today and every day we
seek your guidance and
direction we listen for your still Small
Voice we come before you this morning in
prayer trusting that you will lead us in
our work today
oh God settle us this morning so that we
can approach the work that is set before
us and help us to complete that which is
on the agenda
today together may we Forge forward with
all the legislation presented
today guide our discussions with each
other help us to listen to each other
and give each other the respect that we
want in
return oh Creator God when we listen to
each other without competing
conversations at the same time we are
listening with our hearts for your
instructions in this often chaotic world
may we be the calm and the example for
all to follow let us be an example for
our constituents so they will respect
our leadership and representation for
those we
serve I pray and ask that you lay your
hands upon each member of this New
Hampshire house because we are your
children and you know each of us by
name as it is with our nation the United
States of America let it be known that
in the great state of New Hampshire In
God We
Trust we trust you God to be amongst us
today to guide us in our discernments on
each piece of legislation
presented with your guidance we serve
not only our constituents
Faithfully but we also serve you
Faithfully through our work today we
amen the chair recognizes the member
from blend andary represent Tom Dolan
Allegiance
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the rep stands
Nation
all the chair now recognizes Miss Tasha
lasson ninth grade Preparatory School
anthem oh say can you
see by the da early light what so
proudly we ha at the Twilight last
gleaming who's brought stripes and
bright stars through the
parous fight or the ramp parts we
watched were so
gallantly streaming and the rockets red
glare the bombs bursting in air gave Pro
through the night that our flag was
still there oh say us that star spangled
wave for the land of the
[Applause]
[Music]
the house will attend to request for
leaves of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Buras gold Kate Murray
nordgren Pimon PV Rulo trevan the day
important business representatives ducet
bville and Vincent the day illness in
the family representative Maria Perez
sandborn and Ward the day death in the
family representative prome
O'Brien
these absonant shall be granted unless
otherwise ordered by the house house
will attend to the introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome Tanya
Jerry Adria and Ka Lawson Josephina
senson Regina bla and Nolan Richards
family and friends of the singer guests
of Representative kutab Bob scolly and
Paul gaso guests of Representative Drago
Ron Den guest of Representatives Lynn
and cab the honorable Joyce Weston
former member from Plymouth and Sally
wistrom guests of Representatives Bolton
shirtliff and Weber they are with us in
the gallery
today welcome to the no Hampshire
[Applause]
house the house will attend to wait
communication Mr
Speaker in a letter dated January 31st
2024 Mr Paul Smith dear Paul please be
advised the following Representatives
elect were sworn into office by the
governor and Council on this day Coos
County District number one Shan C Durkin
Coos County District number six Michael
P Murphy sincerely David M scandin
Secretary of
house
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
pursuant to house rule 47f
representative Wier is wave the second
249 the house will now attend to
Memorial remarks for the former
representative from Hein The Honorable
Susan Smith chair recogniz the
representative
Weber
good morning
friends these are Memorial
remarks on the passing of The Honorable
Suzanne
Smith Suzanne served eight terms in the
New Hampshire house house from 2008 to
2022 representing Hein holderness in
Plymouth member of the committee on
environment and Agriculture and then the
committee on resources Recreation and
development where she served both as
ranking member and
chair in the words of the honorable
Joyce Weston who is here with us
today our wonderful Suzanne has
died that sentence says it all Suzanne
fought a long battle with cancer and her
courage and Grace were an inspiration to
all of
us Suzanne was a professional homeopath
and certified nutritionist a former
Natural Food Market Bakery and Deli
owner she met her beloved late husband
Dr John Lloyd and her stepdaughters
Eliza and Ma while living in Stow
Vermont and they moved to Hebron New
Hampshire in
2022 she was a devoted wife parent
friend she was co-chair of the Hein
Conservation Commission she was a
devoted friend
of the Hein Town Forest where she was
also a dedicated Trail
Builder she was a master bder and
treasurer of the New Hampshire aabon pmy
Baker
chapter among her many interests and
accomplishments she she was a
conservationist a paddler a bder a hiker
a wildlife tracker a scuba diver a
singer a dancer an actor a jewelry
Creator an editor a reader and a local
library
volunteer she loved exploring the
natural world not only the mountains of
New Hampshire where she had climbed all
the 400
Footers but also traveling throughout
the United States and further
abroad she had a particular love for and
knowledge of New Hampshire's lakes and
for her work to protect the quality of
New Hampshire's Lakes both in the
legislature and as a volunteer in the
community she was recognized in
2022 as the very first recipient of the
Reverend Stanley lovet Memorial award
for exemplary Lake
advocacy a quote from the present ation
of the award is representative Smith is
well respected amongst her peers on both
sides of the aisle and recognizes that
clean and healthy Lakes are not a
partisan issue she demonstrates
compassionate collaborative leadership
in the pursuit of proactive protective
environmental legislation and has
volunteered countless hours in this
endeavor globally she served on the
border Board of homeopath paths Without
Borders and as Treasurer she traveled to
Haiti where she volunteered at a clinic
for underserved persons and served as a
homeopaths once when there was a
fundraiser here in the house um there
was a lobster boat ride and several of
us realized after a few days that we
were all bidding on it and bidding
against each other so we formed a
Consortium and six of us won a lobster
boat ride with the
honorable David bordon from
Newcastle and on a shining summer day we
went from Newcastle out to the aisles of
scholes and we went to Star Island where
we explored the island and when we were
ready to go back to the boat
Suzanne laed joyfully off the dock and
swam
back she had so many things that she
wanted to do that she didn't have time
for all of them she loved acting she
acted in The Sound of Music imagine our
suzan as a
nun and would have loved to do more but
day she was a thoughtful collabor ative
and effective
legislator a respected colleague and a
friend to all of
us this is where we usually say rest in
peace but for
Suzanne I like to think of her leaping
you can we all rise for a moment in
silence
for what reasons the member rise Mr
Speaker I move we place the memorial
remarks in the permanent journal without
objection the house will now attend to
calendar Mr Speaker from the committee
on state federal relations and Veterans
Affairs cacr 20 removed by
Representatives Terry ghard Tom Manion
Granger pole santonastaso Kelly Hines
Bailey and mcarter from the committee on
state federal relations and Veterans
Affairs house resolution 20 removed by
Representatives Moffett Hobson Healey
Spain gagy Rollins Tom Manion lungren
Edwards and KRS from the committee on
Transportation House Bill 1447 removed
by Representatives parall Corman pelog B
rung Kaplan Wendy Thomas gerana muns and
McGee are there any other bills
removed representative Osman moves at
the consent calendar with the relevant
amendments as printed in today's house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those have fa to say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the consent calendar is adopted under
rules of the house from the committee on
environment and agriculture HB 1626 FNA
is referred to the committee on Ways and
Means for the committee on Health and
Affairs hb1 1278 FN is referred to the
committee on Ways and Means Committee on
state and federal relations and V
Veterans Affairs HB 1355 FN is referred
to the committee on finance from the
committee on Transportation hb32 FN is
referred to the committee on
finance the house will now attend to the
regular
calendar chair recognizes a clerk Mr
Speaker Representatives Osborne and
willhelm move that house rules be so far
suspended as to permit Drafting and late
introduction of a bill relating to a
Care speak thetion chair recognize
motion thank you Mr Speaker good morning
um I first of all I would like to
apologize for having to do this as the
chair of this committee that um this
bill was created by um I thought I had
done my due diligence to make sure that
the LSR came in on time but did not I
would ask um your support and this
important committee's work which is a
unique bipartisan multi-stakeholder
effort to solve a major societal problem
we've spoken with the leaders of both
parties and they are both in agreement
that this is an important issue and we
all ask for your support thank
you
question all those in favor say I I
2/3 de no
debate CH committee on children and
family law to which was referred hb1 199
FNA an act relative to Services of the
office of child advocate for youth ex
expensing homelessness and making an
appropriation thereof having consider
the same report the same with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
are
for for what for what reason does a
member rise a motion to table
sir that is a proper motion
the motion before us is to table House
Bill 1 99 FNA a division has been called
seats make sure everybody turns on your
voting
stations
C
the motion before us is to table House
Bill 1 199
FNA this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds thumbs up represent
ran just a thumbs up or thumbs down
thank
you
representative
toll you can't vote with your button I
you
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 187 voting yay 188 voting nay the
motion fails we're back to the original
question of ought to pass on House Bill
FNA are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oos
n the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
finance
debate committee on children and family
law to which was referred House Bill
1588 FN act relative to court
jurisdiction over persons receiving
special education considered the same
report the same with a recommendation
that the bill ought to
pass pres of Gabby Gman for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
I those oppose nay no the eyes have it
and the committee report is
too majority of the committee on
children and family law to which was
referred house bill 1598 FNA an act
relative to the Department of Health and
Human Services management of Social
Security payments veterans benefits for
children and Foster Care considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass s
of Lorie ball for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate sen of David
bigford minority of the committee
question before us is the autop pass
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay you guys have it and the committee
report is
the
and
jity of the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which was
referred House Bill 1237 FN act relative
to the use of unmarked or self police
vehicles for traffic enforcement
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senat
Jonathan stone for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
chair recognizes representative
alisandra
Murray thank you Mr Speaker and good
morning to my colleagues um members of
the bill before us now is an important
first step in restoring public trust in
our local law enforcement and demanding
transparency and accountability from the
government this legislation requires
that any Municipal police vehicles
purchased after January 1st of 2025 must
be marked if there they are to be used
for routine traffic Patrol this bill
does not prevent any undercovered
detective work or other necessary uses
of unmarked police vehicles this change
is not abnormal as similar legislation
has been passed in 17 States in
Washington DC data has IND indicated
over and over again that marked police
vehicles reduce traffic violations and
encourage safe driving if your priority
is more issued tickets sure keep things
the way they are but if your prior
priority is safer roads and fewer
traffic violations this bill is how we
get there I would ask my colleagues who
prioritize Public Safety and government
accountability to vote no on the
committee's itl motion so a better
motion can be made and so I can
introduce my floor Amendment thank you
Stone
thank you Mr
Speaker this bill clearly targets
municipalities only many of these
Municipal Police agencies operate within
limited number of unmarked cars and
resources in many cases officers fill
dual roles to include administrative
detectives in addition to patrol and
Motor Vehicle
Enforcement this is an unfunded mandate
that would force all municipalities and
would possibly have a fiscal impact for
over 200 towns and 13 cities in New
Hampshire should we be micromanaging our
law enforcement agencies and
municipalities should we not allow
individual cities and towns to decide
what tools are best suited for their
individual Community
needs when we see an increase in traffic
collisions and fatal accidents will we
stand up and take responsibility or will
we point the finger at the police for
not enforcing laws after we handcuff
them this bill is very vague yet broad
it raises more questions than it should
to Be an Effective law for example would
this mean that if an unmarked police
vehicle observes a traffic offense he or
she has lost the police Powers if they
observe a speeding vehicle must they let
go and if so the speeding vehicle causes
an accident strikes a pedestrian or
otherwise causes injury or death is the
officer municipality exempt from
liability what offenses are considered
traffic enforcement a majority of Motor
Vehicle violations are indicative of
driving under the
influence will we be asking police
officers to use a crystal ball to see if
an operator is under the influence prior
to initiating a motor vehicle stop and
making contact with the driver this bill
is silent on the definition of what
constitutes a traffic
law the US Department of Transportation
national highway safety commission tells
us that approximately 15,000 motor
vehicle related deaths occur annually on
our nation's roadways each year and
reducing speed is a high priority and
objective to effective speed enforcement
is essential to the countermeasure to
risks to that end the development
comprehensive speed enforcement
guidelines for law enforcement a key
part of those guidelines includes the
use of both marked and unmarked police
vehicles in order for municipalities to
apply for and receive Federal grant
money for traffic enforcement there must
follow the guidelines if the bills were
to become law we would be passing an
unfunded mandate cutting off their
access to Federal money and telling them
how best to keep their local communities
safe I have not heard one compelling
argument for not using unmarked police
cars for Motor Vehicle
Enforcement is the point of policing to
get citizens to the Bay of the laws only
when they feel there's an immediate
police presence or all the
time will this bill serve the interest
of Public Safety or is it because some
of us don't like getting caught breaking
itl representative Muse has asked for a
division vote this will be a division
yet
it's appropriate to ask this time it is
appropriate to ask a roll call has been
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
vote
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1237 this is a
division vote chair recognizes
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the use of unmarked cars for
traffic enforcement can put drivers
especially female drivers in situations
where they are uncertain if a vehicle
pursuing them is an actual police
vehicle or an impostor and if I know
that numerous studies show that visible
law enforcement uh that highly visible
law enforcement reduces crime rates and
that marked Vehicles actually deter
traffic violations and if I also know
that this bill has no immediate
financial impact because it doesn't take
effect until until January 1st
2025 then would I press the red button
to defeat the itl motion so another
motion can be made thank
you chair recognizes representative Roy
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill only targets
municipalities and lets the state police
who have the most unmarked vehicles and
write the most tickets alone if I know
that this bill is properly debated in
the town halls where they have to
actually pay for the police cruisers and
if I further know that budgets for 2025
are being done now so it does have an
immediate effect on
municipalities and finally Mr Speaker if
I know that the state police actually
who are not involved in this spoke out
against it and said that it will hurt
law enforcement and the ability to stop
people from committing crimes would I
then vote against this Bill thank
you the motion before us on House Bill
123 7 is a majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislate this is a
division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds represent
[Music]
Weber representative Julie
sites have all members voted that we
vote 162 voting yay 213 voting nay the
motion
fails represent representative Alexandre
Murray offers floor Amendment
it's in your seat
pockets are you ready for the question
on J recognize representive Murray speak
to her Amendment thank you Mr Speaker um
this amendment makes a very small
exception to this bill it allows for any
officer in an unmarked vehicle to still
make a traffic stop if they observe a
potential DUI potential reckless driving
or any other immediate threat to Public
Safety so so this addressed a lot of the
concerns that were brought up in
committee by law enforcement and I think
is a great compromise for us to make
thank
you the motion before us is the Murray
floor Amendment
03458 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the floor amendment is adopted the
motion before now is UT to pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I oppose nay no
the eyes have it and
de
speak for what reason does the member
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker State
396 that is a proper motion he speaks
first thank you Mr wait AE wait a minute
order chair recognizes representative
Michael
Cahill thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr
Speaker HB
396 involves a lot of very complex
issues that most of us us have little to
no experience with and with that in mind
I've reconsidered I'd ask you to do the
Lynn thank you Mr Speaker uh colleagues
I won't I won't spend a lot of time on
this no nothing really has changed since
we voted on this on January 3rd let me
just take very brief
to go over the bill this bill creates an
exception to uh the human rights act
that permits but does not require
classifications based the member will
suspend this is on the motion to
reconsider not the content of the bill
okay all right that so basically ask
yourself I guess has anything changed
that uh that our original vote in favor
of this bill um uh was the appropriate
one I submit to you respectfully that it
is and I ask you to press the red button
uh not to reconsider this thank you Mr
Speaker a division has been
called roll call who who requested a
roll
call is it it's sufficiently second roll
call has been requested is sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
recognizes
people
clear the motion before us is the re the
reconsideration of House Bill
396 this is a division vote chair
recognize representative Weber for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that there are some members
who did not fully understand the nature
and the content of this
bill and if I know that they and perhaps
others might like an opportunity to
reconsider the bill would I ask you now
to vote Yes on reconsideration and press
the green button thank
you chair recognizes representative ly
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill was thoroughly explored by both
sides uh on January 3rd that there was
no confusion on anybody's part uh I
submit to you respectfully then would I
press the red button uh to not
reconsider this uh the vote thank
you the motion before us is the
reconsideration of House Bill 396 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
seconds
yeah
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote 187 voting yay 190 voting nay house
will be in order the motion for
reconsideration
fails
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which was
referred House Bill 1372 FN act relative
to prohibiting
torture house will be in order getting
awful
noisy an act relative to prohibiting
torture having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate Senor Terry Roy from the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass s of Jonah wheeler for the minority
of the committee there is no debate but
a roll call has been requested and it is
properly seconded so members take your
vote
wav
off
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legisl on House Bill 1372 FN this is
going to be a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Roy for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the members of the
committee agree that torture is horrible
and should be unlawful but I further
know that it's already unlawful and the
members of the committee could not think
of one instance or thing that would be
considered torture that's not already
illegal in this country and if I further
know that we don't make every single
thing a law that is already illegal for
example we don't have a law against
human sacrifice because it's murder
would I vote with the committee to keep
this bill off the books because it's not
necessary thank
you motion before us is the inexpedient
to legislate motion on of on HP 13372 FN
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
seconds
[Music]
representative
up
all members president had an opportunity
to vote household attend the state of
the
vote 319 voting a 58 voting nay
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs to which was
referred House Bill 1068 relative to
establishing a blood Le level testing
requirement for children entering
daycare and public schools this comes to
us without recommendation representative
Weber moves ought to pass the chair
King thank you Mr Speaker and good
morning members of the
House the great philosopher Yogi Bara
once said it's deja vu all over
again you may remember HB
1068 in the form of HB
342 just last year no we're going to
hear how HB 342 passed through the body
last year and that is true you'll also
hear that the other body on the other
side of this wall passed this this bill
last year also true but then it died on
the governor's desk this too is
true you'll hear this bill is merely a
checkbox for those families with kids
under the age of six when entering
school this is true too you will hear
that this that it is important to
discover lead poisoning in kids at an
early age this is true
too what you won't hear is the
unintentional consequences such as
asking daycare centers in our public
schools to become the policy agent a
policing agency that is create that will
create extra hours to process the added
paperwork this bill will create also you
won't hear about the barrier this will
create for kids entering School
all this while we already have laws on
the books concerning blood
level blood Le level checking and
educating parents of children under the
age of
six so we have the same bill the same
concerns this bill
creates the same house the same body on
the other side of this
wall and the same
Governor you might ask yourself is a
checkbook check box really necessary for
something we already address in other
laws just to see if we will receive
different results this
year join me in selecting the red button
so another motion can be made and Mr
Speaker I would like to request a div
division vote thank you Mr
Weber thank you Mr Speaker
I I wasn't going to say all of that but
I agree with my colleague on much of it
what I need to say is this is not going
to result in an awful lot of extra
paperwork because it's just adding one
more line to paperwork that's already
required about as we've
said a testing that is already
required the reason to bring it back is
that lead is still a terrible cognitive
and developmental danger to
children and the effects of lead
poisoning lead to increases that are
unnecessary in our school
budgets in addition to the fact of lives
that could have been made better
so what we are asking for is once again
to say the right thing to do is to add a
line to the form
it's not going to present any barriers
to entry because it's just informational
if the test has not been given nobody's
going to Bar people from
school so I ask you very from the bottom
of my heart for the children to do this
one more time thank you the house will
button who requested a roll call who
roll call has been requested and
obviously sufficiently seconded this
vote
seat JB
JB
the motion the motion before
1068 this is a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know this bill
will ask our schools to become
enforcement agencies if I know this will
cause schools to create hours of work to
administer the paperwork needed to
capture this data and Mr Speaker if I
know we already have laws requiring
children to be tested for blood level
blood Le blood levels would I now select
the red button to so another motion can
be made thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative Weber for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank thank you Mr Speaker if I
know that this was the right thing to do
the last time for our children and for
our schools and if I know that it is
still the right thing to do would I now
press the green button thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 1068 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposer
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 189 voting yay 190 voting nay the
speaker did vote
representative Bill King moves itl in
expedient to
legislate are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
nay the eyes have
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs to which was
referred House Bill 1520 FNA
establishing a family assistant car
ownership pilot program in the
Department of Health and Human Services
this comes without recommendation
representative Shapiro moves ought to
pass chair recognizes representative
kushman
than
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
colleagues this bill would establish a
pilot program in the
State uh which would partner with
non-governmental organizations to
purchase refurbish and transfer
ownership of used vehicles to certain
um
uh what's it called tant also known as
cash assistant Ware
recipients um it would appropriate
$220,000 to be matched by federal funds
DHHS uh assumes the overhead to vendors
to be 10% leaving about 396,000 for
vehicle purchases at an estimated
vehicle the pursuit to help alleviate
the burdens of people financially
struggling is noble and I commend the
sponsors of this bill for their desire
to do good however there are some
reasons why this pilot program is not a
good idea first of all it's already been
done so it's not really a pilot program
um they had a program in this state and
it was discontinued and there are many
reasons why that may
be the used car market is incredibly
inflationary with limited inventory the
estimated cost for each used vehicle in
this program is very high even in an
inflated Market it's not clear that even
if a recipient can get off of
Transitional Assistance due to receiving
a vehicle that the $20,000 the state
invested in the vehicle would be off
offset by the decrease in future
benefits that's one of the principal
arguments in favor of the bill
additionally there are logistical issues
with the bill concerning continuing
maintenance for the vehicles with used
cars there's always a likelihood of
unforeseen mechanical failure and issues
that can result in the vehicle becoming
inoperable and requiring extensive cost
for repair if a person can't afford to
buy a used car is it certain they can
afford to continue with the maintenance
even if the vehicle is warrantied for a
year
every year used cars can cost thousands
in repairs instead of making monthly
payments on brand new cars people who
have used cars are constantly paying to
keep
it there's also a limited ability to
detect and prevent fraud in this in this
proposed program as a recipient who
takes ownership of veic of a vehicle
through the through the program could
turn around and sell it they do take on
full ownership it's not clear that the
program is a wise investment for the
state due to the many logistical issues
it prevents for the government that's
charged with carefully handling taxpayer
money programs like this are best left
to private Charities and private
donations the legislature like Charities
to their donors have a fiduciary duty to
the people there are currently charities
in New Hampshire that are doing this
wheels for wishes Helping Hands of
America and taking Take the Wheel New
Hampshire and there are National
organizations that help also Charities
and businesses are working together to
meet these needs in the community
my friend is borrowing my car right now
I'm in the Jeep today because she's got
the Honda uh our family only owns used
cars by the way and um the last month
the Jeep got a new starter new tires uh
we need that in the winter so we just
put it back on the road we took it off
cuz it needed repairs put it back on for
the winter um the Honda got tires last
year but it still needs a gauge cluster
which we're having a hard time finding
um all I can say is thank God my husband
is a mechanic because the costs to keep
our used cars would be even higher than
they already are so I don't see the
imperative for this bill it's not wise
and further I don't understand um why a
charity that's meant to help people
won't help people in New Hampshire
without this bill as one of the
Charities that um voiced their uh
support for the bill headset I don't
understand why certain
nonprofits um will offer charity without
State funding but others can't all of
this can be done in the private sector
with voluntar voluntarily donated funds
if we have organizations that are doing
this already the social workers at the
office of um Transitional Assistance
should be helping by referring to those
Charities that exist spill creates a
program that's not wise investment and I
ask that you would support um I ask that
you would vote against the ought to pass
motion and support so another motion can
Shapiro Mr Speaker and fellow members I
speak to you today in support of House
Bill 1520 a bill that creates a pilot
program to make cars available to a
small number of tanif recipients who are
who are already ready to leave New
Hampshire's cast cash assistance program
for needy families in order to become
self-supporting and
independent underlying many of our
debates in Health Human Services and
elderly Affairs is the question does the
state and federal social safety net
tanif snap Medicaid does it promote
wellness and resiliency or does it cause
dependence and dampen motivation to move
ahead in one's
life one thing we do agree upon in
committee there are many many obstacles
to single parents that single parents
face when trying to climb out of poverty
to live a life with meaningful work
Quality Health Care adequate food and
ability to give their children a pro
promising
future one of those challenges is
transportation in a rural state with
limited public transportation options
getting to work is synonymous with
having a
car we all know about the inflated costs
of used automobiles not to mention the
cost of Maintenance and repairs gas
Insurance how can one find and maintain
employment without Dependable
Transportation with HP
1520 Department of Health and Human
Services Division of economic stability
will offer a select group of recipients
who are ready to go from tanif to
self-sufficiency the means to success an
automobile the program will be built to
succeed eligible candidates will have
participated in many educational
programs available through New Hampshire
employment program they will have taken
courses in financial literacy in job
Readiness and all things automobile
related in many cases they will have
received training and certification
related to specific career path perhaps
in health care or child care or the
construction trades these are employees
need we will not be Reinventing the
wheel in fact for 15 years the state of
New Hampshire had a very robust car
acquisition program through good news
Garage in spite of documented successes
in terms of high numbers of people
leaving public
benefits cost savings related to
benefits not used used and low
percentage of recidivism funding for the
program lapsed in
2017 currently you can donate your used
car to Good News garage if you live in
Massachusetts Vermont or New Hampshire
but unfortunately low-income adults can
only receive a car if they live in
Massachusetts or
Vermont if we Value Independence and
self-sufficiency let's give people the
tools they need to to achieve it we know
that if you want to get to work if you
want to get your kids to school if you
want to go to the doctor there is no
tool as valuable as a car please push
the green button to vote or to pass on
House Bill
1520 thank you and I ask for a division
vote does a member yield a
questions no member does not
yield the motion before us is a to pass
on House Bill
1520 this is a division vote members
seats
the motion before us is a to pass on
house Bell 1520 this is a division
vote chair recognize representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this program is not a wise
investment and comes with complexities
that are Bel better dealt with in the
private sector and if I know that this
is currently being done by private
Charities without government contracts
and tax revenue expenditures would I now
press the red button so another motion
can be made chair recognize represent
Mr Speaker if I know that all of us
given the choice would choose a life of
Independence and
self-sufficiency and if I know that a
life on
tanif temporary assistance to needy
families is a life in
poverty and if I further know New
Hampshire social safety net programs are
not intended to be permanent but rather
a means to move parents parents towards
the Dignity of meaningful work and
providing a good life for their children
and Mr Speaker if I know that buying a
reliable car for those on tanif is often
financially Out Of
Reach and without a working automobile
successful employment is considerably
more difficult would I then push the
green button to truly give families the
assist that they need to
succeed thank
you motion before us is a to pass on
House Bill 1520 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
representative
Schmidt
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will 10 stay
vote 184 voting yay 193 voting nay
motion of a pass fails sen kushman moves
in expedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
I those oppose
it's
the committee on Judiciary to which was
referred cacr 23 relating to the right
to abortion providing that all persons
shall have the right to abortion prior
to 24 weeks comes to us without
recommendation representative marjerie
Smith moves a to pass representative tol
motion
he
hello Mr Speaker and members of the
house I stand before you today in
support of a critical effort that
transcends party lines and speaks to the
fundamental rights of every individual
in New
Hampshire I stand here today as one of
the millions of people who has had an
abortion when I was a teenager I
accessed abortion care that has allowed
me to go to college to graduate school
to receive an me to teach and to be a
state
representative and it allowed me to have
my children when I was ready both
physically and emotionally including the
baby girl I gave birth to just last
week as many of you are aware the
landscape of reprodu Ive rights in
America shifted dramatically in
2022 when the Supreme Court overturned
Ro versus Wade with more than 20 States
enacting abortion bans leaving one in
three women without access to abortion
in her home
state we as state representatives have
the
responsibility to protect abortion
rights in New
Hampshire we have the responsibility to
protect every individual's Liberty
privacy and freedom when it comes to
personal reproductive
decisions granted Staters should not
have their Reproductive Rights on the
line every legislative session with
bills seeking to ban abortion earlier
and earlier in
pregnancy because while abortion is
currently safe and legal here we have
zero state or federal Protections in
place for abortion rights in New
Hampshire we can change that cacr 23 is
a bipartison proposal to explicitly add
the right to Safe legal abortion up to
24 weeks in our state's Constitution and
puts the decision in the hands of
patients and doctors not
politicians We Trust doctors We Trust
patients and we trust Granite Staters
with voting on this question I won't lie
it has been challenging just a week past
the birth of my daughter to consider
giving a floor speech for so many
reasons having my third child a little
girl has reinvigorated my commitment to
making sure that every Granite stator
including Daniela has the right to make
their own reproductive decisions I want
my kids to have have the right to
self-determination in these decisions I
want Granite Staters to know that their
reproductive decisions are their own and
I want voters to weigh in on this
important issue we need to send this to
the voters and let the voters decide I
hope you will join me in voting in favor
of cacr 23 to protect abortion rights
from future legislative threats to trust
women and doctors
send this question directly to Granite
sters let's take conversations
outside the I mean a quarter of you are
gone and it's still noisy there's just
no
excuse I'm sorry continue send this
question directly to Granite Staters
thank
you
that you know at some point there there
are Avenues to enforce rules I don't
think anybody's going to be particularly
happy if we start doing that so you can
necessary
representative kab is recognized to
motion thank you Mr Speaker abortion is
currently legal in New Hampshire through
24 weeks and Beyond in in the case of
fetal fatal fetal abnormalities or when
the mother's life or health is at risk
polling data has made clear that the New
Hampshire majority of New Hampshire
citizens are in favor of the law as it
stands today this proposed cacr seeks to
make two big changes from the law as it
is today first it establishes that quote
every individual has a fundamental right
to abortion end quote every individual
is pretty ambiguous it could be
interpreted to mean that everyone and
including the father could demand an
abortion simply because he didn't want
the woman he impregnated to have his
baby it could be further interpreted to
mean that a man also has a
constitutional right to an abortion and
let's say wisely that a hospital denies
that man an abortion does he then have
an equal protection claim against the
hospital this could be fixed by amending
to say every pregnant individual instead
secondly the resolution provides for
abortion post 24 weeks when necessary it
is unspecific as to what necessary means
and would ensine a vague standard into
our constitution necessary could allow
an abortion to be performed right up
until birth simply because a woman
wanted one and a doctor felt it was
necessary to honor that wish there is no
need to put such a problematic CC a
constitution because abortion is already
legal in New Hampshire and women already
have the freedom and reproductive
Liberty to make these decisions with
their healthare
providers so let's vote red on this and
wait until we can get the language right
and respect what the majority of New
you representative marjerie Smith has
Speaker I love this body I've been here
since
1996 a long
time and I still love it I love being in
this
room I love looking at all of your faces
I love seeing you age along with me and
I love seeing the young people
who have joined
us we
are the best legislature in the United
States there are 400 of us we each
represent basically a handful of Voters
3,400 voters we go into the grocery
store and someone comes up to us and
says about such and such a bill what are
you thinking that doesn't happen in
other
states we come as close as you can to
having not a representative democracy
but a direct democracy I was sad when
durm voted to become an sb2 town because
I thought there was nothing better than
sitting in a gym and being able to see
all of the citizens of the
town talk about a particular issue and
that is something that I think is
incredibly important what does that have
to do with what we're talking about here
today I'm looking around and I will tell
you my baby is 54 years old it's been a
while since I have been involved
directly in the
reproduction
business and I'm happy for
that my my
grandchildren though are of an
age where this matters directly to them
but it's not only my grandchildren or
your grandchildren or your children or
you every one of us is affected in one
way or another
by how future Generations decide to
act for years this state was a
Libertarian State a a classic
libertarian state where we said the
government should stay out of Private
Business and it is a time when this
legislature almost always in the control
of the Republican Party recognize that
and respect Ed personal privacy personal
privacy was
Central and we trust our
voters we saw just last week that
contrary to all of the media reports an
incredible number of people turned out
to vote because in this state we take
seriously our
responsibility to
government I cannot think of an issue
that comes closer to affecting the lives
of every single person in this state
than the issue that we have before us
today in this Constitutional
Amendment up until the Supreme Court
acted several years ago we would not
have had to do this but the Supreme
Court has said to each and every state
it is the state's
obligation to de side about issues of
Reproductive Rights and if the state
doesn't take that
responsibility we're leaving a hole in
the fabric of our government and in this
state we have always believed that it
should be the people who decide 3,400 of
them elect
us we hear every bill that people want
us to to consider we do all of these
things we believe in limited government
in this state yes it is true that at the
moment there is
legislation on the books that says 24
weeks for an
abortion and that is absolutely true but
we have several bills on the calendar
today that would change that and nothing
can stop stop us from getting a dozen
more next year and the year after and
the year after except one thing and that
is if we once and for all say that 400
of us cannot fit in a doctor's office we
shouldn't be there it should be the the
woman the person involved her family the
people she chooses to invite into that
room and we should decide once and for
all that we have a lot of very important
business in this state and we shouldn't
be wasting our time with trying to
intrude on people's private
decisions I ask you
today whether you favor 24 weeks or 24
days whether you favor any restriction
or no restriction I ask you today in the
interest of limited government and
respect for the individuals who elected
us here in the first place to pass this
Constitutional Amendment with the hope
that the Senate will also pass the
Constitutional Amendment and in November
we would send the issue to the voters
and let the people decide thank you very
Speaker the question before house is the
ca23 representative tki request a roll
call vote is that sufficiently
seconded and it is this will be a roll
seats
e
clear
[Music]
the question before the house is the
motion of about to pass on
ca23 this being Constitutional Amendment
concurrent resolution a vote of 3 fifths
of the membership of the house is
required for
passage representative Lynn is
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that because the current fetal
Life protection act enjoys widespread
public support among New Hampshire
citizens of all Stripes there simply is
no threat to abortion rights in this
state despite the NeverEnding political
rhetoric to the contrary and therefore
this proposed constitutional amendment
is totally unnecessary and if I know
that the vague wording of this amendment
would allow abortions to be performed
virtually up to the moment of birth if a
woman for whatever reason felt that
abortion was quote unquote necessary and
could find a physician willing to bless
her decision and finally if I know that
the vague wording of this amendment
which grants the right to abortion to
anyone also carries the potential of
allowing a man who has impregnated a
woman to insist that
she abort the child even if she does not
wish to do so in order for example for
the man to avoid responsibility for pay
supporting the child then would I vote
no on this very ill-advised proposal by
pressing the red button thank you Mr
Speaker representative chur recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that Granite Staters value their
personal freedom and liberty Above All
Else and do not want the government
involved in the most private medical
decisions they make with their doctors
and their loved ones and if I know that
the majority of granite Staters
consistently say that they want this
right which they had known for 50 years
explicitly restored to them in our
state's
Constitution and if I know the proposals
that we now see each year about new
abortion restrictions at 15 days or at
15 weeks cause great concern for women
and families in our state and that these
can be put to rest if we amend the
Constitution with this language
protecting the right to choose up to 24
weeks as it is in current law and
finally if I know that amending the
state's Constitution is not done by us
but by us simply choosing to send this
question to the voters where it has a
very high 2third threshold for
passage wouldn't I now press the green
button pass this cacr let the people of
New Hampshire decide if they want this
right to keep us out of their most
private decisions codified in our
cherished state constitution thank you
Mr
Speaker the question before the house is
a motion about to pass on CAC R23 and
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
vote 193 and the affirmative 184 and the
negative it fails to meet the threshold
motion
fails
ch majority of the committee on
Judiciary to which was referred House
Bill
10002 act relative to fees for records
under the right to no law consider the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and recommendation the bill
ought to pass with Amendment sen Caitlyn
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate sen of
Louise Andress for the minor of the
committee the amendment is 01
97h printed in house record 4 Page
30 are you ready for the question the
question is on the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the amendment
is adopted the motion before us now is
the bill ought to pass with
Amendment chair
Dolan first of all I sit on this side of
the room but I think that Freedom of
Information and government transparency
is a bipartisan
issue
little closer how am I doing
now uh I'd like to set a set the scene a
little bit in
2017 this body this body issued a final
commission report on
hb178 it was a legislative study
commission which studi the processes to
resolve right to no complaints in New
Hampshire in that report the commission
accredited and took as true a study on
right to no request s the Center for
Public Integrity a winner of the Pitzer
prize evaluated the Freedom of
Information laws in all 50
states in the category of public access
to information New Hampshire earned a
grade of F and ranked
49th out of 50 coming merely one point
ahead of Wyoming which had the worst
score in the category titled in citizens
can resolve appeals to access
information request within a reasonable
time and period cost the Hampshire
received a score of
zero that is from a commission report of
this
body 91a the Preamble for 91a States
openness in the conduct of public
business is essential to a Democratic
Society and we are 49th in the country
in regards to access to
information would this bill make us 50
we are only one point away from being
50 this bill is not the answer it limits
freedom in particular Freedom of
Information it will actually increase
litigation the people that might be
abusing the system will have another
claim of action against agencies they
can simply say the agency is improperly
asserting the amount of time it takes to
address a
request or it'll block someone
requesting something in good faith
because they can't afford or they don't
want to put the effort or cause trouble
by suing the agency to enforce the
statute this is an
overcorrection of the problem of
addressing a few bad
actors now I want to bring your
attention to part of the 91a statute in
particular particular the portion titled
remedies the court May award attorney's
fees to a public body or public agency
or employee for having to defend against
the lawsuit under the provisions of this
statute of this chapter when the court
finds that the lawsuit is in bad faith
frivolous unjust wanted or
oppressive so there is already a
narrowly tailored solution to bad faith
and Bad actors in the
law that allows push back on actually
frivolous request and lawsuits but also
allows good faith
request the statute itself is already
the
solution a judge can punish someone
abusing the system and they can also
vindicate a citizen for a violation of
91a this bill can only punish good faith
acting citizens because there's already
a remedy for Bad
actors we can only go one spot lower we
are 49th let's not become 50th let's
honor the Preamble of
91a openness in the conduct of public
business is essential to a Democratic
Speaker chair recognizer Senator Michael
O'Brien
thank you Mr Speaker and good morning
colleagues uh as many of you know I do a
lot of things so wife will tell you I
think I do too much and I have to agree
with you but the thing is one of the
other jobs that I have is a vice
president of the board of alderan in the
city of Nash but I'd like to keep my
comments away from nashor per se but we
can use that as the
example now the thing is NASA does not
want to limit any right of a citizen to
get
information we meticulously in nashille
have our meetings televised on closed
circuit
TV people can turn in and they can see
it if you don't or if you missed the
meeting because you were busy or
something like that you can go to
channel 16 and see the meeting again
because they
rebroadcast and I'll also tell you when
the dump is
open but the thing is
uh there's plenty of access to the
information number two we
meticulously every uh minute or
everything that is discussed at an
automatic meeting and all meetings is
copied
verbatim verbatim if you were to look at
our particular uh meetings you can get
rece re a hard copy in
time of word for word of what was spoken
at the meetings now some communities
maybe perhaps yours takes a synopsis but
we don't we documented to the
tea and so with these things if anybody
wants information it's there but it
takes it may take some time to access
but particularly if something that was
spoken once and then several months have
gone by there's a lot of meetings in
nashwa I have a meeting just about when
we're in session just about two three
meetings a week between either being
Lea's on or my committees so the
information is out there but then I got
to bring up what would you
do if you had a
citizen who without benefit of an
election feels that they have been
appointed by I don't know who the dog
catcher or something like that but they
are the people's
Watchdog and
demand access to every access to the you
know some of the things that happen at
the meetings in the in involved in 91a
we
have but then it comes down to we have a
legal department and legals got a lot of
things on their mind there's zoning
things that we got to work on there's uh
others uh contracts that need to be
negotiated and signed and as it turned
out you say this has no impact on any
minp IP ality I assure you it does
Nashua had to go out and hire another
lawyer and I'm sure that lawyer is
getting you know what U you know makes
some the amount of what a lawyer makes
taxpayer and
particularly one bit of information
leads into another bit of information
and some of this stuff is personal in
nature uh such as uh Personnel type of
issues and employees issues and is some
things that need to be
redacted so this takes time for legal to
look at
it so you say it has no impact to the
municipality it does I can
attest Mr Speaker that I can show you
documents of requests about this
thick of what was you know
supplied enough is enough particularly
if somebody wants to do the research and
spend the time and go through the
documents again we have a website many
your communities do as well too so
somebody can go through the
website but I want to end this in such a
way to let you know Nation Joshua
supports the right to know
law but when it comes
down when do we have the break point of
too
much and that's what I want you to
consider in voting this the regular
requests are fine but one is too much
too much now you
say
$25 that's a little bit too much but
what happens to the
information if they go out and get a
lawyer and take you to court which has
happened that $25 fee gets rolled into
if they win their Court decision so they
get it
back okay so it's not like it's not
missing or anything like that it's this
has the backing of the New Hampshire
Municipal Association not to shut or
shut down a person's
inquiry into what city government does
but it's trying to make it a little bit
more practical and again I feel like by
me getting up and as a representative of
Nashua speaking on this I just put a
Target on my back but this isn't the
first time I have you know but
I want you to leave you with this
thought as an alderman in the city of
nashwa I get paid
$5,000 a
year okay some might say that's a lot
but the amount of meetings that we go to
and everything my wife doesn't think
it's
enough but the thing is do I want to go
to conquered
prison for violation of the the public
trust for
$5,000 I
mean you do the
math okay I was born a nice Catholic kid
I'm going to live with in the confines
of the law I am not going to get in
trouble because I feel I have dedicated
my life to public
service so I'm asking you to stand with
us and support this bill because this
doesn't eliminate requests to the
91a all it does is the second and third
when it gets over a certain amount of
time and that's when we need to address
the issue and maybe it makes the choices
of the requests far more practical than
just spouting off that we're going to
make the request and I thank you Mr
Speaker so therefore I urge you to
support this Bill thank
Andreas thank thank you Mr Speaker good
everyone I am here
today to adamantly
test testify against house bill
one2
the last updated memorandum from the
Attorney
General on New Hampshire's right to know
law
2015 House Bill
102 goes against the
Constitution and New Hampshire right to
know the following is a quote from the
attorney general's m memorandum
quote the Public's right to
know what government is doing is a
fundamental
right in New Hampshire's
democracy New Hampshire's Constitution
and the right to know
law
ensure that the public has reasonable
access in meetings of public bodies and
the government's records when New
Hampshire's Constitution was adopted in
June of
1784 accountability of public servants
to the
people was established in part one
article 8 which reads all power residing
originally in and being derived from the
people all the magistrates and offices
of government are their substitutes and
agents and all times accountable to
them in 1976 the people of New Hampshire
amended part one article 8 of The
Constitution enforcing the existence of
a right to access to public meetings and
Records by adding the following two
sentences government therefore should be
open accessible accountable and
responsive to that end the Public's
right to access
governmental proceedings and Records
shall not be
unreasonably
restricted according to house
bill2 a public entity May
charge the requestor up to $25 an hour
if the time to
obtain information is in excess of 10
one this discriminates against the
citizen that cannot
afford and the CH cannot afford the
charges but wants to know what the
government is do is doing on the same
subject of retrieving records person
number one might take 5 hours to
retrieve information and person number
two for whatever reason may take 11
hours to retrieve the same
information who
determines an amount of estimate of time
to retrieve
information number three and this is
just this is just a
scenario and this could happen what if
the employee decides to take 11 hours
even though it doesn't take that long to
retrieve the information on Char and
charges is $25 an hour or
$275 and the recipient cannot afford to
pay that person is stripped of his right
to know what is going on in his
government the judicial committee at its
public
hearing heard testimony and the
testimony mainly was on sizable requests
from commercial
recipients
why does every person in New Hampshire
suffer and pay high fees for right to
know
information because of the problem
between business and an uh public
entity I also understand that on
occasion a large request will be
made which is costly and the the person
never picks it up therefore it is costly
to the
municipality rather than passing House
Bill
102 with up to a $25 an hour charges the
attorney general who I understand is
updating the right to know memorandum
should become involved with logic and
Common Sense and help solve the problems
rather than us passing house bill 1 oot
which is
unnecessary on reviewing the house
online
testimony
submissions I noted that 10 supported
house
102 and 20 opposed that signed
up there was also testimony online and
in person from the New Hampshire municip
Municipal
Association the nhma
information stated that on August 21st
2023 an nhma launched a member survey in
responding to write to no
request the nhma noted that as of August
29th
2023 70 municipalities
responded the total V viewed stated that
I looked up that there are
234 municipalities in New Hampshire 221
towns and 13
cities yet the response rate on the
30% 164 mon municipalities were not
included in this survey therefore the
information submitted and testimony by
the
nhma was
insufficient therefore without without
insufficient data from all the 20 other
234 municipalities on the right to no
request I could
not make an informed
decision for the citizens in the state
of New
Hampshire there are many unanswered
questions regarding right to
know there is a real W is there a real
widespread problem with right to know
requests or are the right to know
requests minimal problems and data from
all the municipalities is necessary to
ascertain the
answer is the Attorney General's
office involved to
discuss and find Common Sense solutions
to the problems if not the Attorney
General's office in my opinion needs to
step up to the plate so to speak and
help solve the
problems are all public
bodies trained appropriately in the
right to know law and right to know
requests do all
municipalities maintain accurate records
in appropriate and orderly manner as
stated in the New Hampshire statute
chapter 33 colon a disposition of
municip IAL
records all people in government whether
elected or volunteers or
employees serve the citizens of New
Hampshire right to know requests how the
way the people get to keep government
transparent in their
actions and the actions of the office
without right to know there would be no
way to keep government at all honest and
transparent the citizens pay taxes to
government and citizens have a right to
know how their money is spent and
policies made with minimal charges to
the requested
information with House Bill
102 being able to charge up to $25 an
hour for retrieving
records if the time to retrieve exceeds
11 hours again is discrimination against
people that cannot afford the
fee therefore their right to know what
is happening in government is
violated I ask
you to press the red
button and on no on a to pass on House
Bill
102 and Mr Speaker I request the
Lynn thank you Mr Speaker as amended
this bill allows governmental bodies to
recoup the costs of what are in in
effect extraordinary right to know
requests those that take over 10 hours
to process and respond to this is
enabling legislation governmental bodies
are not mandated to impose these charges
costs allowed cannot exceed $25 per hour
o if once you go over 10 hours and
charges imposed must be reasonable
reasonableness can be reviewed by the
right to no on budsman and ultimately by
the
court before costs can be charged under
the amendment the public body must
articulate its policies so that the
public knows up front what charges may
be
imposed approximately with with regard
to this the suggestion that somehow you
know this bill is uh is kind of out of
Step approximately 37 other states have
laws like this they have they impose
condition costs in different different
ways I'm not saying that ours is you
know there's uniformity but 37 other
states have uh Provisions for imposing
costs um so I submit there really is no
substantial issue as to the court as to
the Bill's constitutionality part one
article 8 of The Constitution does not
confer the right to get any amount of
records from the government for any
reason at the cost of the taxpayer
that's the important thing here the fact
that you have a right to certain records
doesn't mean that you have the right to
get them for free that's you know you
you have the right to travel under the
that's a fundamental right under the
Constitution that doesn't mean the
government has to buy you a car or that
you can't be charged tolls on the the
road um it it's just that one doesn't
follow from the
other the purpose of this uh bill is to
avoid Shifting the costs of very large
requests from the tax from the person or
company making the requests to the
taxpayers of the municipality or the
taxpayers of the state to the to ensure
that governmental bodies can receive at
least some compensation when their
employees are distracted from their
regular duties to respond to such
timeconsuming
requests the 10-hour threshold ensures
that for the vast majority of what I
would refer to as normal requests no
charges will be imposed most large
record requests are from commercial
Enterprises which can afford to pay and
will simply pass such costs on to their
customers but our committee heard
testimony from local officials in a
number of places throughout the state
that there are some requests that are
abusive where people make the request
not because they really want the
information but just to harass and
inconvenience the municipality because
they believe there's some conspiracy
going on or whatever um people make and
and as evidence of this probably the
strongest we there was one witness I
recall testifying that they literally in
this town they have a they have boxes
and boxes of of requests that people
have where people made requests the
governmental body complied and nobody
ever bothered to pick them
up um the last point I would make is you
heard one of the prior speakers refer to
the fact that there's a provision under
the under the rights of no law that
allows a governmental body to seek um to
seek uh costs and other remedies if if
there's an abusive request that's that
that's there and it has it it you know
it it it's not really much of a of an
effective remedy and and the reason for
that is this under the right to no
law the person requesting doesn't have
to say why I want the information or
what I'm going to do it what I'm going
to use it for or whatever they can
request you know they they they can
basically say listen you know I have
trouble sleeping at night so I want I
want to know the date of birth of every
person that was married in New Hampshire
over the last 50 years you and I might
think that's crazy what why but that you
can't ask that question why do I why do
you want the information so it's very
very difficult to S to to to to um to
enforce the idea that something is
abusive because they they on what
grounds on what grounds is it abusive I
I want this I want these records it's
yeah it's a lot of Records but so what
that's my right I want the
records this requires in in what in in
circumstance where there's an
extraordinary request this requires that
the person have at least some skin in
the game and I think that in these
circumstances that's really
appropriate um so I for all of those
reasons I believe that this is a this is
a entirely appropriate bill that will
address the problems that we that that
uh have been uh have been identified and
will not have the will not require us
all of us taxpayers to Bear the burden
in these situations and I think that's
entirely appropriate uh you you can get
the information but at at a certain
point you got to have some skin in the
game you got to pay for it for those
reasons I ask you to support the OTP
motion thank you Mr
Speaker Senator vandas has requested a
division this will be a division
vote a roll call has been ask for is
seconded yes it is sufficiently seconded
members will take their seats this will
Tim
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of to pass as amended
on House Bill
10002 this is a roll call
vote chair recognizes represent of
inquiry Mr
succeed if I know Mr Speaker that this
bill would severely
harm government accountability and
transparency in New
Hampshire and is opposed by a broad
Coalition of stakeholders including the
ACLU New Hampshire Americans for
Prosperity um the New England First
Amendment Coalition the New Hampshire
press Association the New Hampshire
union leader the New Hampshire bulletin
the New Hampshire Liberty Alliance and
right to know
Hampshire and if I
know that the right to know law is an
incredibly useful tool in identifying
systemic government abuse it has exposed
police misconduct how various agencies
regulate how our laws are enforced and
how we are
taxed and if I know that this bill will
give government agencies a significant
tool to obstruct providing this Vital
Information to taxpayers who should not
have to pay for either an agency's
overzealous attempts to keep information
secret or the agency's poor document
management policies and lastly if I know
the committee did not consider more
targeted proposals that could limit
excessive requests without deterring the
Hampshire residents from making
reasonable requests for documents and
there are already
mechanisms in New Hampshire law that
check against frivolous requests when
the court finds that the lawsuit is in
bad faith frivolous unjust vexatious
wanting I don't know about that word or
oppressive would I now press the red
button so that another motion could be
made chair recognize her magl ery for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know from my long experience on the
select board that people in companies
sometimes take advantage of the right to
know law to engage in fishing
expeditions
and if I know that those fishing
Expeditions take Municipal Employees
away from their assigned tasks and cost
taxpayers significant dollars and if I
know that the Attorney General's office
stated that the implementation of a
reasonable fee system for large right to
no requests supports the spirit and
purpose of the right to know law and our
state's Constitution's principle of
reasonable access to governmental
records and if I know know that the data
gathered by the New Hampshire Municipal
Association that this bill will only
provide a local option that would only
affect large requests and help provide a
mechanism for municipalities to uh and
requesters to collaborate and if I know
that this bill eliminates surprise fees
provides a mechanism to appeal the right
to know Ombudsman and the right to no
law already provides for a no filing fee
for Indigent appealing to the OD
bunman then Mr Speaker would I press the
green button to accept the committee
report thank
you the motion before us is the majority
committee report of aut to pass as
amended on House Bill
10002 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
e
Representatives M harri
please
sir all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
vote 193 voting yay 179 voting nay
adopted announc just we have three quick
lunchtime
announcements uh chair calls
representative
goalie
thank you Mr Speaker members of the uh
legislative Sportsman's caucus are those
interested in learning more about it are
invited over to lunch at the Apple
marker house uh at the break Fred bird
the assistant State manager for the
Northeast uh for the Congressional
Sportsman foundation will be our guest
speaker thank you chair recogniz
representative cordelli for
announcement thank you Mr Speaker we'd
like to have a a brief meeting of the
sponsors of
hb67 the safe haven baby Bill uh right
over here underneath the state
flag chair recognizes the
clerk thank you Mr Speaker this is a a
message for all
members a number of members have
received postal mail containing
communication with offens offensive and
derogatory comments some of those
letters have been delivered here to the
state house by uh the Postal Service our
Protective Services team is monitoring
the content of these communications and
has shared them with the Department of
Justice at this time there is nothing
that has been determined to be criminal
in nature or otherwise actionable
however we do invite house members who
have received any similar communication
to share it with the speaker's office
myself or protective services so we can
determine if any other letters may have
different messages in them that are
either criminal in nature or actionable
thank you
hous is in recess
until
1:30
house will come to
seats the committee on Judiciary to
which was referred House Bill 10005 FN
an act relative to judicial training
having considered the same report the
same the following Amendment a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senor Richard trip
for the committee the amendment is 01
93h printed in house record 4 Page 31
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it and
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
adopted
oh sorry 1005 is going to finance this
be this to
finance uh 105 the one we just voted on
finance the committee on judiciary to
which was referred House Bill 1248 FN
act relative to restriction on access to
abortion having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution that is inexpedient to
legislate Zoe Manel for the
committee for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion State your motion
Mr Speaker I move to indefinitely
postpone hb1
1248 that is a proper
motion
the motion before us is to inde
definitely postpone House Bill
question uh representative Weber
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
vote
the motion before us in House built 1248
is indefinite
postponement this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
for
represent
yes of all members presentent and an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote
nay majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred House Bill 12:30 an act
relative to establishing a committee to
examine weatherization initiatives for
homes in New Hampshire considered the
same and Report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate Senate Michael
Harry from the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majorized as
representative
Kaplan thank you Mr Speaker and good
afternoon
Representatives hb1
1230 intends to identify the current
state of weatherization of homes in our
state including the number of homes that
are properly weatherized and those that
are not assess the economic and
environmental benefit of weatherization
such as reduce energy consumption lower
utility bills decrease greenhouse gas
emissions analyze exist analyze existing
weatherization programs and policies at
the local state and federal levels
engage with stakeholders and develop a
comprehensive set of
recommendations we all know by now I
hope that there's a housing crisis in
our state it has been well documented
and there is plenty of data available
both through our state agencies and non
profits such as the New Hampshire
Housing Finance
Authority no County in New Hampshire has
a rental vacancy rate higher than
3% inventory of homes is at historic
lows there is a plethora of data
available to policy makers who are now
taking action to remedy this
situation the lack of available housing
is exacerbated by an affordability
crisis a recent study concluded that of
all the possible occupational categories
in our state only
before Engineers electricians police
officers and registered nurses can
afford the medium rent of
$1,500 none of the occupations listed
could afford the median home
price
$430,000 to the point of this bill the
lack of Housing and affordability crisis
is magnified and exacerbated by the
substandard weatherization state of our
housing stock for which there is no hard
data what we do know is almost 40% of
housing in the state was built before
1970 these units are often more
affordable to rent or buy but they can
be very expensive to heat or cool due to
the substandard insulation and
weatherization of these homes counties
with the highest share of units over 50
years old are Coos 53% chesher 49% and
Sullivan
49% yes there are existing
weatherization programs the New
Hampshire saves program run through the
utilities and the weatherization
assistance program run through the
department of energy together these two
programs weatherize approximately a
th000 homes per year a drop in the
bucket of the current need quantifiable
only to the extent that project
proposals far outweigh the budgets for
these programs year after year without
fail what is the current need of
weatherization where is it needed
exactly we don't have a clear picture
other than it's large
solving the problem of weatherization of
homes is crucial to solving the larger
housing crisis in our
state the benefits of having an
adequately winterized home should be
obvious to everyone here it makes a
difference in the lives of our
constituents who are the most likely
people to be living in inadequately
weatherized homes they are your
neighbors people with disabilities
single parent households Black and
Hispanic families the most likely people
to be living in substandard housing
every community in our state has a good
share of housing stock whose residents
are paying over and above what they
should to keep warm this hurts all of us
the New Hampshire saves program
estimates that it adds $3 to the local
economy for every dollar invested in
their
programs and no matter what accounting
you use improving the quality of life
for our constituents is why we are
buttons figuring out ways to collect the
data that we need assessing the programs
and policies currently in place
especially given the large amount of
federal dollars coming our
way Gathering input from stakeholders
these are all the first steps to getting
a handle on a crucial aspect of our
housing crisis or we could look the
other way and congratulate ourselves on
doing what we do best sometimes it seems
count on things to take care of
themselves and rely on the resilience
for which Granite Staters are
famous I get study committees are just
not that
exciting but having one can be the
jumping off point for getting something
big done where a big job is needed when
I saw that this Bill had nine
co-sponsors in this house and three
across the wall I thought well there you
go there's two committees right
there three representatives and one
Senator meeting for less than a year to
take to make a report doesn't seem like
a big ask put me down for one of the
spots
so if you think that assessing existing
programs and data collection on
weatherization is an important task of
oversight which properly belongs to the
legislature if you think that helping to
fix our housing crisis helping stop
waste and unnecessary pollution
improving local economies and helping
families live better quality lives are
all things your constituents appreciate
then please vote against the itl motion
so that a better motion can be made and
I request a division vote Mr speaker
thank you
Harington thank you Mr Speaker so let's
take a little look at this bill and see
what it actually does as stated it has
four members on it so these four members
are going to have a lot of work to do
starts out by saying quote identifying
the current state of weatherization in
our state including the number of homes
that are properly weatherized and those
that are not the department of energy in
their testimony said the department is
unable to identify the number of homes
throughout the state that are not are or
not weatherized New Hampshire does not
maintain any type of database that
tracks residential homeowner
installation of a given energy
conservation measures so the entire
department of energy can't do what these
four members of this committee are going
to do Mr Speaker if this is passed in
committee it goes on to say that they're
going to look at comprehensive set of
recommendations and incentives to
weatherize weatherization efforts in our
state well what that basically means is
how can we figure out a way to get more
money out of the rate payers and the
taxpayers to give to someone in a
weather rise their house it doesn't
mention anything about con cost
Effectiveness whether these should be
cost beneficial measures that just says
anything we can do to spend other
people's money and it doesn't also
mention that there's huge amounts of
money being spent by the state right now
we got a massive Grant from the federal
government under the
weatherization weatherization assistance
program this past year uh I think it was
$18 million uh through the New Hampshire
saves program we spend tens of millions
of dollars a year on Energy Efficiency
and weatherization and in fact New
Hampshire is ranked in one of the in the
top states in the country as far as
dollars spent per capita on Energy
Efficiency and weatherization so in
summary we have a study committee that's
impossible to do their task because the
whole department of energy says they
can't do it so certainly four
individuals can't it has no mention of
being cost effective let's just go spend
other people's money and it doesn't
discuss the fact that we already have
multiple programs in effect to take care
of weatherization of private housing so
please join me in voting in favor of the
itl
motion
representative cap Kaplan has asked for
there this will be a division vote
seats
yeah
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1230 this is a
division vote chair recognizes
representative Kaplan for a
parliamentary
inquiry if I know that helping to fix
the housing crisis starts with Gathering
data and stakeholder input and assessing
current
programs if I know that holding on to it
and bringing our existing housing stop
stock up to standard in terms of
weatherization and insulation is crucial
in our tight housing
market if I know that economic growth in
our state can only happen if we can
retain and attract young people and
working families with decent
housing and finally if I know that a
commission to study this crucial aspect
of our housing
crisis would be welcomed by all the
agencies and
nonprofits associated with housing in
our state
what I vote read to oppose the
itl chair recognize representative votes
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire will spend
$450 million over the next five years on
Energy Efficiency 60% of which will go
to home
weatherization if I also know that while
some of that money will come out of the
pockets of federal a
taxpayer uh many of whom live in this
state most of it will come out of the
pockets of gas and electric rate payers
here in New
Hampshire and finally Mr Speaker if I
remember and I am old enough to remember
this the Arab Oil Embargo of the early
1970s and the long lines at gas stations
that we had and the torrent of policies
and dollars that were spent to deal with
Energy
Efficiency and home
weatherization policies that persist to
this
day what I now press the green button to
acknowledge that we don't need to study
weather home weatherization any further
thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is a
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legisl in House Bill 1230 this is a
division vote for in favor you'll press
the green button if you oppose you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
represent
Rich if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house attend to
state of the
vote 240 voting yay 33 voting a
adopted committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred House
Bill
1398 en act relative to utility recovery
of costs associated with net energy
metering having considered the same
report the same with a recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study Senor Michael votes for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
adopted committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred House
Bill
1499 act establishing a committee to
study the civilian clean energy
Community resilience and conservation
CES and considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senator Michael VES
for the committee the amendment is 0102
H printed in house record 4 pages
33-34 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay you guys hav it
amendment is adopted motion before us
now is ought to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those suppose n the eyes
have it and the committee report is
adopted
okay what we have
here is cacr it's got to pass but it's
on second reading so Bernard is going to
move
speak we have a roll call on both the
amendment and the CAC
committee on state and federal relations
and Veterans Affairs to which was
referred CAC
r13 an act relating to slavery and
involuntary servitude providing that
slavery and involuntary servitude shall
be prohibited in the state of New
Hampshire having considered the same
report the same the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass it's an a mandat
committee representative
Bernardi offers floor Amendment
03858 it's in your seat
pockets and the chair recognizes
representative
Bernardi thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to
support this amendment and let me just
read it for you it's very simple neither
slavery nor involuntary servit servitude
except as punishment for a crime whereas
the party shall have been duly convicted
shall exist in the state of New
Hampshire or any other place subject to
its jurisdiction now you may recall that
this language is identical to the 13th
Amendment of the United States
Constitution except substituting New
Hampshire for United
States adopting this identical language
and having having this hearing on this
bill helps tie us to the historical
precedent of all the past cases where
this where this issue was litigated most
particularly the issue involuntary
servitude I'd just like to digress for
one moment to talk about the 13th
Amendment and how it was
passed in the Senate the vote was
38-6 all the Republicans and only two
Democrats voted for it in the house the
vote was 119 to 56 all the Republicans
and 14 Democrats voted for it I'm hoping
that we'll have a broader bipartisan
response to this particular
version it was submitted to ratification
on the 1st of February
159 years ago today it's the only
amendment that was signed by the
president President Lincoln signed it
before he sent it out New Hampshire was
the 23rd of the 27 States required to
ratify
it it makes sense to adopt this because
it's parallel language to the US
Constitutional Amendment and that again
carries in all the history of all the
litigation and all the hearings that
have been conducted on this subject if
we just adopt the current version that's
been proposed we're starting as if it
was from Ground
Zero
now you may ask
why would we want to do
that you
know we all know the Claremont case was
decided by the meaning of the word
charity written in our constitution from
1784 excuse me cherish not
charity
so what we see is evidence that
historical precedent historical language
is looked at by the courts when they
examine the meaning of a particularly
Amendment most
importantly the issue involuntary
servitude was raised in the dobs
decision invol pregnancy being carried
to full term was proposed to be
involuntary
servitude the court rejected that
finding we bring that history into our
decision today if we adopt the full
language as it is proposed in this
amendment that same logic of
having uh pregnancy be considered
involuntary servitude in my mind is
similar to saying parents are invol
voluntary servants to their children
until the age of 18 this is just not
logical yet it is out there and it is a
case that people are talking about
bringing
forward so I urge
bipartisan passage of this amendment I'd
like to see everyone vote for
elimination or Banning of both slavery
and involuntary servitude in New
Hampshire thank you Mr Speaker does a
member does not yield chair recognizes
representative
wheeler thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues9 years ago to the
day we had the debate in the United
States Congress around the issue of
slavery 159 years ago to the day January
31st
1965 and I think it is precient that we
are here today discussing this same
debate having the same debate that they
had in
1865 the debate before us is whether or
not to approve this amendment and I'd
just like to speak for a second about
that the state and federal Relations
Committee approved the language of the
original Bill 20 to Z and there were
some concerns brought up by the chairman
around prisons and what the position of
commissioner the commissioner of our
prisons and what their position would be
about this legislation they came and
offered a letter in support of the bill
as it stood originally and that was
because commissioner Hanks the
commissioner of our prisons and
ourselves understand that slavery is a
moral wrong
it's an excuse uh for something that
doesn't exist anymore and folks this
is a tough issue and and all of us here
you know think I think some of us might
think that this issue has already been
solved uh but I would like to to posit
that and the hearing for this bill
happened on National human trafficking
awareness day and I and I think that was
another one of the coincidences in this
bill which point to support there are
1.1 million people in the United States
right now who are classified as being
slaved uh enslaved in either sexual
servitude enforced Labor uh human
traffic 1.1 million people is the
estimate of how many people right now in
the United States are enslaved and
that's why there are days like human
trafficking awareness day that's why we
care so much about human trafficking
because this has been recognized as an
issue that is a moreal wrong so the
amendment here before us today would re
authorize the same language that's
currently in the United States
Constitution's 13th Amendment the
problem with that language is it leaves
there an excuse for slavery and in my
opinion as someone a student of History
uh there should not be any exemption for
slavery uh slavery in any form is wrong
and commissioner Hanks agrees with that
the 20 members of the committee agreed
with that when you have an issue where
the Liberty Alliance and left-wing
activists are together on the same issue
and then you have some centralists in
the same who are on the same issue I
think that's an issue that's worth
supporting because people on all sides
the on the aisle whether wherever you
fall on the economic spectrum or the
social Spectrum agree that servitude
involuntary servitude for another is a
moral wrong and as we stand here 159
years ago to the day of when the
Congress of the United States debated
this amendment as I stand under Abraham
Lincoln who helped pass this amendment
and saved our Union in that moment and
as I sit in my seat as someone who would
not have been allowed in this
building not that long ago within some
of our lifetimes here I think for me
this is one of those legisl this is a
legislation that's clear to support and
I understand the concerns that were
brought forward but I have to say that
legislative intent is an important thing
and the legislative intent of the
committee had nothing to do with the
other things that were brought up by my
friend at the other Das the legislative
intent of the committee had to do with
abolishing slavery once and for all so
this didn't have to do with abortion
this didn't have to do with any other
issue other than slavery and and I think
trying to dilute it by bringing up those
other issues does this let legislation
of
disservice so my friends colleagues I
would ask you again just as the United
States Congress did 159 years ago to
vote against this amendment and vote for
the bill as ought to pass because
slavery is a moral wrong all of us in
this building understand that and there
is no exception to that so thank you
very much so Mr Speaker and I app
appreciate the time you've lent to me
today
colleagues representative Balden has
requested a roll call it is sufficiently
seconded members take your seats this
vote
is
the motion before
us
is ought to on the amendment itself the
amendment is 0385 H this is going to be
a roll call vote chair recognized
representative Berardi for a
parliamentary
inquiry if I know by adopting this
amendment we are adopting if I know by
adopting this Amendment we are adopting
a parallel amendment to that of the 13th
Amendment of the United States
Constitution which has served us well
for 159 years would I now press the
green
button chair recogniz repr D Lorenzo for
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that no committee has ever
reviewed or considered this amendment
and no public hearing has occurred and
if I know that the committee passed the
underlying Bill
2020 in unanimous participant support I
mean by bipartisan support um and if I
know that the Department of Correction
supports the bill as is and that no one
spoke against this bill during the
public hearing then what I now press the
red button to oppose the
unreviewed 11th Hour Amendment so we can
proceed to pass the approved language
thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
Bernard floor Amendment
0385 H this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
s
all members present had an opportunity
vote 168 voting aay 201 voting nay the
amendment
fails we are now on to a to pass on CAC
r13 chair recognizes
sign
okay the been informed there is no
debate on the bill representative Balden
has requested a roll call it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
seats
the motion before us is aut to pass on
cacr 13 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you press the green
button if you oppos you press the red
it
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote
366 voting yay five voting nay committee
report is adopted for what reason does a
member
rise I would move to put the debate in
the be in
order I would move to put the debate in
objection committee on state and federal
relations and Veterans Affairs to which
was referred House Bill 1179 FN relative
to State Park system fees for retired
members of the Armed Force
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment so Michael Moffett for
the committee the amendment is 01
92h printed in house record 4 page 32
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it
amendment is adopted motion before us
now is ought to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
adopted we have a one-onone debate
Rangers requested it's goings
minut uh and this one is going to Ways
and
Means majority of the committee on state
and federal relations of Veterans
Affairs to which was referred House Bill
1338 act relative to New Hampshire's
enforcement of military Selective
Service Act having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate presentative Linda masa for
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with a majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass Tom Manion for the minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative
Manion thank you Mr Mr Speaker I rise
today against the committee
recommendation on HB
1338 the bill supports uh part 1 article
7 of the New Hampshire Constitution the
people of the state have the sole
exclusive right of governing themselves
as a free Sovereign and independent
state prohibiting uh sorry prohibiting
New Hampshire resources from being
utilized to identify locate and
apprehend any person for failure to
register or muster for Selective Service
that is the purpose purp of this
bill it also repeals New Hampshire's
Selective Service registration awareness
and compliance act which mandates that
individuals be registered for the uh for
the draft to be educ eligible to attend
State Higher Education to receive
education grants from the state and even
bars them from employment with the state
for failing to register with an upcoming
floor Amendment
uh it will address the concerns from the
comme about the an additional check box
that would register someone as a
conscientious objector so hopefully we
get through this uh while when I filed
this bill it seemed like a just inase
Safeguard against an unlikely chance
that the draft was restarted to
supplement the proxy war in Ukraine
however in the span of only four months
the corporate news propaganda machine
has given a new given us a new but old
Target the neocon white whale AR
every day there is news about another
iranian-backed strike against us
Personnel in and around Yemen Iraq Syria
and now Jordan the war drums are beating
and it feels like 2003 all over again it
should be noted that Iran is bigger than
Iraq Afghanistan and Syria combined with
much stronger military more dense urban
areas than Iraq and similar mountainous
areas that hindered our operations in
Afghan istan and don't for one second
believe the same propagandist that fed
us the lie in 2002 that the Iraqis would
welcome us as
liberators which was followed by a
decade of bloody Insurgency in Civil War
during the 2000 surge the Department of
Defense instituted a to a stop loss
involuntarily extending the enlistment
of military personnel and even calling
up the inactive reserve to fill gaps in
the ongoing Wars in Iraq and Afghanistan
and this this was the last Stitch effort
to bolster ranks before enacting a draft
some on the left called it a backdoor
draft at the
time and this is when recruitment was at
an all-time high after the spike of
patriotism and voluntary enlistment
following 9911 we're currently
experiencing record lows in Recruitment
and
Retention so now we're poised with the
media and leaders from both sides of the
warmongering uni party readying us for
hot conflicts the world
over we don't have the numbers to fight
any prolonged War so a draft will be
necessary and while the state cannot
openly oppose the draft we do not have
to help them punish those that do we can
signal to DC that Granite Staters do not
support another bloody Forever War and
especially utilizing conscription to
fuel it I ask that you vote against the
commit recommendation of itl by pressing
the red button so another motion can be
Massa thank you Mr Speaker and honorable
colleagues HB 1338 deals with Selective
Service
registration some concerns the committee
had about HB
1338 were
the conscientious objector checkbox on a
driver's license application and the
section that dealt with prohibiting the
state from cooperating with federal
government laws or an executive order to
assist federal law
enforcement in regards to the con
conscientious objector box the committee
felt it would mislead an applicant to
think that with a flick of the pen the
appc could achieve conscientious
objective status when actually the
process is longer and much more
involved the other concern mentioned
involved eliminating New Hampshire from
working with the federal government
regarding individuals not complying with
the Selective Service
Act if this bill were to pass the loss
to the state could be Federal funding
while the affected IND individuals could
experience eligibility difficulties when
applying for executive branch jobs or
for jobs with the US Postal Service or
for applying for financial aid for
college just to name a
few after talking with the selective
service department it was learned that
the government uses the first two levels
of its total military force namely
active duty members then reservists and
National
Guardsman before initiating a
draft the last time the draft was used
was 52 years ago in
1972 finally even if New Hampshire
enacted
legislation counter to the federal
Selective Service Act an
individual would still be liable for
failing to comply with federal
law please vote to support the committee
recommendation of itl thank you
representative ganger has requested a
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1338 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know we shouldn't punish people and
prevent them from going to College just
because they are
anti-war and if I also know that given
the way things are going in the world
right now War very well may be on the
horizon and given the war fatigue in
this country that that means that a
draft is all but certain and lastly Mr
Speaker if I know that is almost always
the poor that are sent to kill and die
and not the fortunate sons who get
waivers then Mr speaker would I now
press the red button so that another
motion can be
made J I recognize representative mford
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that our
nation's security depends on accessing
Manpower sometimes necessary for our
defense in times of national Peril and
if I believe that New Hampshire does not
have the power to nullify a federal
measure such as the military Selective
Service
Act would I then press the green button
to support the committee's majority vote
in favor of EX inexpedient to legislate
thank you Mr Speaker motion before us is
a majority committee report of
inexpedient to legisl on House Bill
1338 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you press the green button if
you are opposed you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
vote 266 voting yay 101 voting nay
adopt
majority of the committee on state and
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
to which was referred
hr21 now confirming that New Hampshire
militia considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative saal Lloyd for
the majority of the committee minority
of the committee having considered the
same being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
the bill ought to pass representative
Tom Manion for the minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative
Belair thank you Mr
Speaker good afternoon colleagues it's
it's getting awful loud in here the
member has a right to be speak thank you
article 24 of the New Hampshire
Constitution a well-regulated militia is
the proper natural and sure defense of
our
state this is the exact language you
will find in this house resolution now
when I drafted this resolution the
writing was on the wall the writing is
no longer on the wall the writing is on
the
news look across this country and what's
happening in
Texas as of right right now the governor
of Texas has invoked the Constitutional
provision on
Invasion and activated his State
National Guard to defend the state of
Texas per the Governor from
Invasion there is already
talk in a number of different circles
from leaders of this country of
federalizing the National Guard to
remove the power of the Guard from the
governor of Texas now this act this this
uh resolution is not about what's going
on in Texas right now but this is the
concept behind it in our system states
are the Dual sovereign states have the
same sovereignty that the federal
government enjoys and under the
definition of sovereignty you will find
gets to have their own military
service this is a resolution about the
state militia the state guard in
particular when
Florida attempted to staff their state
guard they came under attack they were
threatened they were told that they
should not be doing this it was
advertised as if it was some sort of a
some sort of a vigilante thing but it's
it's under State Control it's under the
control of the Governor New Hampshire
also has this same concept in law a
state guard it ex exists it's already
there and if the day comes that we ever
need to staff it we can expect the same
fight and the same threats that Florida
experienced when they tried to staff
theirs it has gotten to the point that
the federal government is treating the
states as if they don't have the right
to their own militaries under State
control that's why I have drafted this
we need to send a signal that we will
not accept being a lesser power we are
not thank
Sebert thank you Mr
Speaker my fellow colleagues I come
before you today regarding hr21 a
resolution affirming the New Hampshire
militia the role and composition of the
militia is already clearly defined in
the New Hampshire statutes specifically
RSA 1
10-b
A-1 these statutes provide for the
provide for the well regulated militia
referenced in the Second Amendment of
the
Constitution as such this resolution is
not
necessary this organized militia
consists of the New Hampshire National
Guard the state guard which have the
proper training and defined roles
ranging from National Defense to
Emergency Response plans that our
citizens have come to depend depend on
when such a need arises the organized
militias consisting of any able-bodied
individuals are already included in the
existing RSA as well and are therefore
already affirmed these are just a few of
the reasons for the committee report of
itl we recommend that you concur with
these findings I thank you for your time
thanks
pres of Belair has asked for a division
vote members take your seats this will
vote
the motion before us a majority
committee report of index speed to
legislate on
hr21 this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative Tom Manion for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that New Hampshire Constitution part 1
articles 25 and 24 as well as the Second
Amendment to the United States
Constitution outlined that an
well-trained militia is a proper natural
and sure defense of a state and if I
know that RSA chapter 111 defines that
state militia as consisting of all
able-bodied and willing people not
currently enlisted in the US or state
military and finally if I know that
bills were filed in DC this year year to
infringe upon these fundamental
responsibilities would I push the red
button to oppose the committee
recommendation on hr21 so another motion
can be
made chair recognize resent Massa for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know in
1879 New Hampshire designated its
militia as the New Hampshire National
Guard and if I also know that with the
national events Act of
1916 New Hampshire militia's name change
to New Hampshire National Guard became
official and finally Mr Speaker if I
know this resolution is
unnecessary would I now press the green
button to support the committee
recommendation of itl thank
you the motion before us majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on hr21 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 226 voting yay 138 voting nay
adopted majority of the committee on
transportation to which was deferred
House Bill 1391 FN an act allowing new
vehicles purchased in the model year or
before to be inspected in the second
year after the purchase considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation Bill ought to pass sen
Matthew Coker from majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
session resolve that is inexpedient to
legislate representative George Sykes
committee chair recognizes
representative
Coker
can't get my butt on thank you Mr
Speaker so my name is Matt Coker I
represent the town of Meredith and I'm
here to present uh House Bill 1391 so
House Bill 1391 is a common sense change
to our vehicle inspection laws basically
it's easier just to give an example it
lets you if you buy a new vehicle go two
years without an inspection so I was
born in March if I go out today to
celebrate this bill passing and buy a
new car um in March of 2026 I would have
to get it inspected for the first time
so uh couple issues with this bill and
this is the things that most of the
opponents are going to bring up is the
safety of vehicle inspections
so I looked around for data and believe
it or not it's kind of hard to find data
on vehicle inspections and the effect
they have on the safety of our roadways
and I found a government accountability
office report that had a bunch of
studies kind of all melded together and
when I looked at that report every study
and this is five or six studies from all
over the world actually it concluded
that there is no Advantage no safety
advantage that we get from vehicle
inspections um and this report was done
on all cars so this bill is only on
brand new new cars so that's very
important to keep in mind we're talking
about a very small sliver of cars and
when you dig into this report a little
bit more they looked at all 50 states so
New Hampshire is actually one of 16
states that still requires vehicle
inspections if you look at the other
states that don't require inspections
there actually is no difference in the
fatality and injury rate so again
vehicle inspections don't tend to have a
statistically significant effect on the
safety of our roadways
um another thing when you dig into this
report a a little bit deeper is the
cause of vehicle uh vehicle accidents
only 2% of them are actually caused by
component failures so the report goes on
to say because this was like a report
about looking into studying vehicle
inspection looked into studying them a
little bit more and the report literally
said like
listen component failures are such a
minor Factor vehicle wrecks that's it's
not even worth researching it we might
as well look into causes of uh vehicle
accidents that are more prevalent um
so it is true that if you look at the
data that some new vehicles do fail
inspection but if you dig into that data
you're going to see that the causes for
those failures is pretty minor so in
2022 880,000 new vehicles were inspected
and of that only 142 failed so that's a
I mean just a minuscule number and out
of that 142 one of the biggest factors
was glass so that could be like a chip
in your windshield that could be window
tenting that could be all kinds of
things the second biggest factor in this
was literally like vehicle information
so we're looking at Vin plates license
plates or possibly a valid registration
so it it's it's not looking like these
aren't real safety issues uh the other
com the other argument against this is
high mileage vehicles
so if you are driving your vehicle and
some people put 30 40,000 Mi on their
vehicle you're driving it for a reason
so you're going to take care of that
vehicle so I again maintaining your
warranty all that stuff you're going to
take care of your car so the uh
inspections I feel are just kind of
redundant and lastly the what they're
going to talk about is the EPA so our
vehicle inspections have emissions
testing added into it
and the emissions testing portion of the
the of the inspection is something we're
going to have to go back and and
reevaluate because the EFA or the EPA
actually requires us to do that and then
we have to talk about our missions and I
guess they have to take it from other
parts so basically what's going to end
up happening is when we go we pass this
law we can go to the EPA and say listen
this is what we've done and you
know considering that this is on the
cleanest I guess segment of our vehicles
brand new cars some of them EV some of
them hybrids it's really not going to
affect our emissions or our air quality
that much and on top of that if you look
at the states around us Rhode Island you
don't have to get your new vehicle
inspected or you don't have to get
admissions testing for two years
Connecticut you don't have to get you
you can go four years so I mean if Rhode
Island and Connecticut can work out with
the EPA that they can go that long
without AEM Mission sessioning I think
new hampsh I'm sure does so lastly if
you look at it you know going to getting
a vehicle inspection doesn't seem like a
big deal but if I say I take an hour out
of your time to go get a vehicle
inspection this bill is going to save
about 80,000 vehicle inspections a year
that equates to 10 years of our
constituents time so given that there's
no real effect on safety there's no real
effect on emissions is it worth it for
us to ask for 10 hours of our con
consent time just to kind of have safety
theater so that's about all I got so
appreciate your time thank you and I
request a division
syes
see so colleagues you just heard a lot
of interesting uh data from the uh the
kind gentleman from uh Meredith but like
all data there's two sides to the coin
and I'm going to try and talk about some
of the other ways that this data can be
interpreted and about some safety issues
so the first thing that you should
remember is that the bill as it is
written possibly is not just about new
cars but rather about cars that could be
two and perh in some cases depending on
the date of birth for the person who
buys it and when the model year came out
could be actually 3 years old and that
means a lot of mileage on the
road
now all of our neighboring states in New
England do have inspection programs and
they vary in the way that they take care
of those uh issues
but we have to be really careful about
how if we look at other states and other
parts of the the country
why those that don't have inspection
programs don't have them they don't have
the kind of road conditions weather
conditions that are prevalent here in
New Hampshire if you think about it the
weather changes here quite
frequently the elevations for roads can
change 89 for instance can be quite
lovely in just a gentle rain but to go a
little further 89 suddenly you got a
little snow blizzard on your hands um in
addition to that here in New Hampshire
they use brine liquid salt water to
treat the roads if you drive over to
Vermont they don't do that so that brine
has an effect on your vehicles and part
of the inspection program takes a look
be I want to talk about how we look at
this safety data
information one of the reasons that um
again my colleague referred to the fact
that there only a couple less than a
less than 200 failures of new cars over
80 uh I think he said 880,000 but let's
review how this process usually works I
don't know about you but I owned years
back a relatively new car and I brought
it in and they found a problem with it
and what did I do I said we just fix it
and they did and they fixed it under
warranty and so while it would have
failed inspection under that
circumstance it actually passed because
I took care of the problem then and I
saved some money while I was doing it so
think about that your constituents
potentially can save money and the the
the amount of new vehicles that actually
fail on first blush is much higher than
suppose the department of
safety is against this bill and one of
the big reasons is that the bill
provides no mechanism for an alternate
for an alternative stickering scheme so
you're the local police officer driving
down the road and you see a car with no
inspection
sticker and what do you do is the is the
car new enough to avoid having to have
that sticker do we put a different kind
of sticker in subsequent legislation I
think we have to be mindful that this is
not quite ready because they haven't
answered that question we certainly
don't want police officers pulling over
all vehicles just because there's a
question about whether they have
stickers or not and they can't answer
that question easily like they do
now I want to talk about the EPA
issue it is true that some other states
have been able
to um modify their agreements for about
uh greenhouse gases with the EPA but we
need to be mindful of this fact here in
the Hampshire more than nearly half I'm
sorry nearly half of the greenhouse
gases come from motor vehicles and we do
not
have alternative sources that the EPA
could say well we can we can you can
forgo some of the yearly in uh EPA you
know
testing and we'll have other industries
make up for it we just don't have those
types of Industries those heavy carbon
polluters they just they're not here in
the state so that's a real issue and
this build does not speak to
how we'll fix that problem if in fact it
comes to
pass you know and I've already alluded
to this but 24 to 36 months is too long
for uh an annual
inspection I don't know how many miles
you put on your car but um many people
will go well beyond the reasonable
expectation for tires they will go well
beyond the reasonable expectation
possibly for breaks um these things
often times people learn of the problem
because they get their vehicles
inspected not everybody is an under the
hood kind of guy or girl who can fix
these things they need that for them
finally a big impetus for this bill
was this sort of feeling that there were
a lot of uh our constituents who were
complaining about the garages were not
treating them
fairly and yet the numbers of formal
complaints is minuscule compared to the
numbers of literally the millions of
cars that get inspected and recently the
DMV has made changes about posting on
your report your inspection report and
there's further work about getting a
poster in the inspection station that
tells you you can call the New Hampshire
Department of Safety talk to the New
Hampshire state police and they will
come down if you feel grieved about your
garage's work you can come down and have
them look at your inspection and say yes
this is correct or no it's not and um
but that does not happen often but it
could
happen
so um if not already requested Mr
Gorski thank you Mr Speaker good
afternoon Co colleagues just like the
pastor in the church when he says
tonight's sermon will be short my
comments will be
brief I stand in support of HB 1391 I
believe 1391 is a logical and practical
change to the inspection program now in
testimony opponents to this bill brought
up issues about cars that are driven
hard driving 35,000 mil 40,000 miles and
the big issue was okay we're not going
to inspect these at 70 or 880,000
miles well I've had the chance in many
in in my past to buy a new car and when
I've leased or purchased a new car I
bring it to the same dealership and when
I bring it to the same dealership they
they honor my warranty but in addition
to that I get a checklist in some cases
15 to 20 points in which they check my
tires they check my fluids to check my
brakes etc etc so the mechanics go
through an extensive or at least a a a
piece of it to go through your car to
find out potential issues so I find that
that that argument is kind of M
so in closing I believe that this bill
is logical and a practical change to the
inspection program I ask you to press
the green M to support this Bill thank
you Mr
Speaker representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the motion before us is the majority
committer report of aop pass on House
Bill
1391 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognize representative
inquiry house will be in
Speaker if I I know that contrary to the
bill but that matters of Public Safety
in this complex world that we live in is
never a simple
matter and if we protect the lives of a
few people by this program isn't that
really part of what we're trying to
accomplish and if I know that this bill
will allow vehicles with high mileage to
go uninspected
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
the number of new cars that fail
inspection I want to repeat this again
is seriously under reported most of them
get fixed right away what I now vote red
so that another motion can be
made chair recognize representative Au
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that only 15 states still
require annual
banal inspections and in New England the
state of Connecticut does not require
safety inspections on personal vehicles
and only requires emissions inspections
after four years and the state of Rhode
Island requires them only after the
second year which is very similar to
this bill and if I know that states that
have discontinued inspection programs
including States like Colorado and
Wyoming with some of the harshest
weather in the country have seen no
discernable increase in accidents and if
I know that this this bill exempts only
a small number of vehicles that are
brand new and that annual inspections
will otherwise still be required just as
they are now would I now press the green
button in favor of the committee report
thank you the motion before us is the
majority committee report of autop pass
on House Bill 1391 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press a
green button if you're opposed you press
a red button voting stations are open
seconds
e
representative
gager all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
241 voting yay 123 voting a committer
report is adopted and this is on to ways
and
consent
committee on state and federal relations
and Veterans Affairs to which was
referred CAC R20 act relating to
declaring independence in the United
States of America providing that if the
national debt reaches 40 trillion New
Hampshire they declare independence and
proceed as a Sovereign Nation consider
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved it as
inexpedient to legislate S A mandat to
committee
for what reason does a member rise make
a motion State your motion indefinitely
postpone C
postpone the motion before us is to inde
definitely postpone takes three fifth of
the membership to pass this so that is
us a division okay this will be a
division vote me the house will be in
order this will be a division vote
because obviously we need an accurate
take represent Howard representative
Howard request a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
vote
e
than
all right the house will be in
order the motion before us is any
speeding to legislate on CAC R20 this is
going to be a division vote chair
recognizes representative San Ando for
parlamentary inquiry
and definitely postpone thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
federal government has no guard rails on
its ever increasing debt and if I know
that no one alive today has consented to
be governed by this federal government
in opposition to the idea of
self-government and if I know that the
federal government is completely Rogue
and only acts outside a law and further
if I know that this Federal Government
taxes its own citizens at 40% just so it
can bomb citizens of other nations as a
matter of
routine and Mr Speaker if I know that
the state of Texas is currently cons
contesting its own sovereignty with the
federal government then when I press the
red button so we can debate our own
State sovereignty thank you Mr
in chair recognize representative
Sweeney for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
there is no practical way for this bill
to move forward or this constitutional
amendment to amend our Constitution and
if I further know it will take three
fifths of our body to proudly uh vote
the green button to indefinitely
postpone this legislation so we do not
have to discuss it again this year uh
would I now press the green button thank
you the motion before us is inexpedient
to legislate in cacr 20 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e
[Music]
represent
Peterson all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 341 voting yay 24 voting nay the
passes the committee on state and
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
to which was referred hr20 enact
reaffirming friendship between New
Hampshire and Taiwan encouraging the
enhancement of bilateral trade relations
and supporting taiwan's International
participation considered the same report
the same with the recommendation that
this bill to pass pres Michael Moffett
for the committee chair recognizes
representative
Wallace thank you Mr Speaker colleagues
I Rise to take a moment to acknowledge
and reaffirm the long-standing
relationship between New Hampshire and
the Republic of China Taiwan our good
friend Taiwan a global manufacturing
Powerhouse that is currently engaged in
commercial trade with New Hampshire
businesses at a rate approaching $250
million a year has been a long time and
strong economic partner New Hampshire
businesses exported 53 million worth of
goods to Taiwan in 2022 those exports
included integrated circuits laths
Machinery light bulbs and many other
products Taiwan would like for their
relationship to continue as it is
mutually beneficial relationship for
both New Hampshire and Taiwan the recent
elections in Taiwan are a good
indication by the Taiwanese
people that their desire is for the
current party the Democratic People's
Party to remain in charge as life is
good for Taiwan at this time and they
wish for the trend of peace and
prosperity to continue the only threat
to Taiwan lies across the straight of
fosa Taiwan is a friend in need of our
support at this time and by passing this
resolution you can join me in saying
just that Taiwan we support you the
methods by which we support Taiwan this
time are suggested in the resolution a
simple driver's license reciprocity
agreement with New Hampshire you drive
on the right hand side of the road over
there by the way a memorandum of
understanding on educational cooperation
between the New Hampshire educational
system and Taiwan English is taught to
every Taiwanese student in all schools
across Taiwan for decades at this point
and advocating for Taiwan to be
participatory in international civil
organizations such as the international
civil aviation organization which has
193 member States presently but Taiwan
is not one of them this organization
exists to Simply uh share Aviation data
in the pursuit of making flight safe for
The Travelers of the world New Hampshire
has a long lasting cultural ties with
Taiwan an interesting historical fact is
my leags also known as Madame Chang
China's Eternal first lady and her
sister Ching Lings the mother of China
learned to swim in Meredith Bay and
attended summer school on Meredith neck
from 1908 to
1913 Madame Chang later had a summer
house in wolfboro and spent many Summers
there until her passing in 2003 at the
age of
105 there are several Madam Chang
artifacts on display at the Meredith
Historical Society she and her husband
president chanai Sheek lived in a
Lakehouse on Sun Moon Lake up on the
mountains in Taiwan I suspect that our
Lake wiip reminded her of Home
although I bet she preferred to SL swim
in our Lake winaki as our lake has much
clearer water it's imperative that we
support Taiwan at this juncture their
young democracy is vibrant and strong
they are the eighth largest trade
partner with the United States and let's
not forget that Taiwan produces 70% plus
of the world's large-scale integrated
circuits absent these chips we would not
be making any phone calls sending emails
or driving any of our cars and trucks
much of the 21st century Life as we know
it would come to a halt you get that
idea we' get back to the anong era New
Hampshire needs the strong ties to
Taiwan to continue as they are as they
are without interruption or less than
productive actions thank you Mr Speaker
vote sen Wallace has asked for a roll
it's it is sufficiently seconded this
vote
yeah
the motion before us is a to pass on HR
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
represent
m
representative
AAR
represent all members present have an
opportunity to vote else will tend to
stay to the
vote 354 voting yay six voting
adopted committee on transportation to
which was referred House Bill 1447
FN can
hear this is the last
bill
an act relative to prohibiting certain
smoking admitted devices on Motor
Vehicles having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
committee chair recognizes
representative
parall
Speaker Mr Speaker you might ask why I'm
engaging the insanity of removing an itl
from the bill on consent I have no
personal
stake well closer is that better okay
thank
you uh feedback appreciated Mr Speaker
why am I engaging the insanity of
removing an it Mobile on consent I have
no personal stake other than I enjoy
driving on calm roads with other
responsible drivers and I support law
enforcement to that
end the Adolescent behavior of what's
called rolling coal is meant to make our
roads more dangerous and irritate other
drivers typically an aftermarket
mechanism is installed that defeats the
emissions control of a vehicle and
allows it to spew noxus unspent black
exhaust at other drivers by bists or
joggers if caught in the act these
drivers can and often are charged with
assault Federal Regulations within the
Clean Air Act have established the
illegality of tampering and defeating
emission control devices and allows the
justice department to pursue legal
actions against manufacturers of the
emissions defeat devices on a global
scale they are vigorously pursuing such
Avenues and have already secured several
claims over $1
million uh the justice department is
currently seeking what might be up to $2
billion in fines against eBay for the
sale of
343,000 of these rolling hole devices
sold between 2015 and
2023 each device being subject to a
$558
fine our own Department of Environmental
Services s New Hampshire testified in
favor of this bill and the modifications
can generate between as the modific
ation of the a car can generate between
40 and 100 times the emissions of a
standard
vehicle so you'll see in the claim in
the house calendar
report that the proposed legislation
already exists under Federal CH uh
Federal Regulation under the Clean Air
Act it does not neither the EPA or the
justice department are in the regular
habit of patrolling our New Hampshire
highways any more than placing agents to
monor the garages that perform per these
inspections so Highway enforcement will
not happen at the federal level which is
why several states have already passed
legislation similar to this rolling coal
bill in order to curb this nefarious
action to State regulation has um no
means of enforcement on the state level
as it does in your calendar to make that
statement um as the reason for opposing
the bill is extremely disingenuous the
entire point of this legislation is to
make enforcement possible
this legislation places the right tool
in the hands of law
enforcement I also want to be clear this
legislation does not Target the driver
of an older vehicle that inadvertently
belches fumes as a former tractor
trailer driver myself I'm fully aware
that these slight transgressions are
sometimes the cost of
operation this is about the local guy
that costs up
$1,500 to Il legally install one of
these devices which are easily easily
identifiable even without belching black
smoke these rather oversized devices are
attached under the hood and an obvious
place the switching devices inside the
cab are also another giveaway not to
mention the oversized exhaust pipes and
if you still can't recognize it another
identifier is the decals that these
trucks often support decals reading
rolling coal black smoke matters Prius
repellent sorry or the obvious I roll
whole it's said that we have no idea of
how often this occurred that was one of
the other comments isn't once enough how
many bank robberies do we let occur
before we take action we have six bicy
we run over in Texas last year by a
teenager that was trying to roll coal
and then ended up rolling over the
bikers instead would be quicker to move
this legislation if one of our children
were victim to
that
they're also debating the meaning of
significant quantities in the original
bill now any modification defeat a
vehicle's admissions control is illegal
under federal law which is why my floor
Amendment strikes these words from the
bill there's a floor Amendment it no
longer says significant quantities it
could be rather nitpicky for to have
this but let's be clear the intent of
rolling coal is to break the law if the
law breaker doesn't succeed in the
as I said these modifications are easily
identifiable and police know how to
enforce laws let me repeat that police
laws with the official while the
official position of the State Police is
neutral in my conversations with the
state police they have said this would
be a valuable tool in their attempt to
calm New Hampshire
roads now perhaps there are flaws in the
drafting of this leg isolation but at
the minimum this bill should be sent to
the body on the other side of the wall
for a deeper dive the only reason I can
think of opposing this is because we
support felons that create unsafe
driving conditions over providing
support for law enforcement suffs to
maintain safe and calm New Hampshire
highways so if you're opposed to
felonious and unsafe driving practices
then help me remove this itl so that
another motion can be brought forward
and let's let law enforcement do his job
and Mr Speaker I ask for division
V thank you chair recognize the
representative
Walt uh thank you Mr Speaker uh the
committee on Transportation voted this
bill down or inexpedient to legislate 17
to Zer for two main reasons one it's
already illegal RSA
26659 very briefly the engine and power
mechanism every motor vehicle shall be
so equipped and adjusted as to prevent
The Escape of excessive fumes smoke
flame gas oil or fuel
residue now this bill is about excessive
smoke but it also comes with an
excessive punishment for an individual
any this is from the bill any person who
violates this section shall be subject
to a penalty of not more than
$5,000 does the punishment fit the crime
the committee on Transportation says no
please join us and support the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker representa Walsh has asked for a
division vote this will be a division
seats
e
the motion before us is inexp to
legislate and House Bill
1447 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Gera for a
parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that what
we just heard was a compelling argument
but what we really need is a serious
debate and if I know that existing
federal laws on this issue are not being
enforced on New Hampshire roads and if I
know that hb1
1447 would allow law enforcement to
police this already illegal Behavior
would I now press the red button to
overturn the it
and allow another motion to be made
thank
you Senator Walsh has waved off so the
motion before us now is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1447 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
e
up of all members president had an
opportunity to vote household attend to
state to the
vote 308 voting yay 46 voting nay
committee report is
adopted everybody needs to stay in your
seats we've got a lot of committees that
might be meeting for executive session
coming representative Osborne
motion the chair recognizes a member
from Auburn representative Osborne for
the third reading motion thank you
resolve that the house now adjourn from
the early session that the business of
the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only and resolutions by
caption only and that all bills ordered
to third reading be read a third time by
this resolution and that all titles of
bills be the same as adopted and that
they be passed at the present time and
when the house adjourns today it be to
meet Thursday February 8th at 10:00
a.m. questions on the third reading
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I oppos nay the
eyes have it the motion is adopted the
announcements chair recognize
representative
Roy please be advised that the committal
Justice committee will be executed
session holding holding executive
session tomorrow on house bills 10:25
1330 1260
1448 in room 202 204 of the legislative
office building at 1:
wer thank you Mr Speaker members of the
finance committee in accordance with the
notice I sent you Tuesday I plan to exec
House Bill 1560 Room 210 11 at 3:45
today please be prompt we should be out
of there by 4
Barry thank you Mr Speaker uh the
esteemed Comm uh election law committee
will meet at 3:30 in room 304 for the
purposes of executive session on House
Bill 1446
1704 1705 and 1699 thank you J recognize
representative
Lynn thank thank you Mr Speaker uh
members of the Judiciary Committee uh
this is to notify you that we will meet
at 3:45 this afternoon in room
26208 to exact the following bills House
Bill
1069 House Bill
1696 non-gain Amendment
2024 - 0237 H to House Bill 1696 House
Bill 1589 House Bill
1651 House Bill
1256 house bill 14 12 we may discuss but
we will not exec or vote on House Bill
16002 thank you Mr Speaker Jer Rec andiz
representative
Aly thank you Mr Speaker on the
Democrats the Democrats in ways and
means that are still in the room on
could we please meet over there uh after
this ends so that we can figure out what
to do about the meeting we were going to
have this
pel all legislators are cordially
invited to attend an openhouse
discussion about upcoming legislation
regarding medical assistance and dying
or otherwise known as state approved
suicide this event will be held in the
upam Walker house on Tuesday February
6th from 10:00 a.m. to 2: p.m. and lunch
will be
provided chair recognizes representative
consent thank you Mr Speaker and Mr
Speaker through you to my esteemed
colleagues of the New Hampshire General
Court I Rise and I ask that my remarks
do be accepted for unanimous consent
Sun and I stand to commend two of our
colleagues today whose trips around the
Sun are not yet have been as frequent as
mine I am proud to have attended a
ceremony this morning at the Secretary
of State's office where secretary David
scanland presented the John Lewis youth
leadership award to two of our
colleagues the gentle lady from Salem
the honorable Valerie McDonald and the
gentleman from Peterboro The Honorable
Jonathan
[Applause]
wheeler
by evidence of the standing ovation I
think we all can agree that we are very
proud of these young citizen legislators
who are the epitome of what this
esteemed award stands for young Leaders
with a passion for social justice and
civic education and a desire to improve
the quality of life in their local
communities both of my colleagues have
demonstrated that here in New Hampshire
as Representatives our first
responsibility is to the constituents
that we
represent they are the heartbeat of our
communities and they deserve the
opportunity to have their voices heard
here in conquer these young
Representatives have made this their
Cornerstone of civic
duty we all applaud them for their
continued service and Leadership for
their respective towns of Peterboro and
Salem to the granted State and to this
historic body so to Representatives
McDonald and representative wheeler for
being an inspiration and role model to
our youth looking to get involved in
helping to make a difference to
embodying and embracing the ideals of
Civic right excuse me civil rights icon
John Lewis in your Civic duties I thank
you and commend you for receiving this
esteemed daughter and to my esteemed
colleagues and Mr speaker thank you for
the opportunity to
speak
[Applause]
Mr
Speaker what reason member
rise I move that the remarks be placed
in the permanent journal without it
without
objection representative wman moves at
the house standing recess for the
purpose of introduction of bills enroll
bills amendments and enroll Bill reports
vacate motions and receiving messages
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I
those oppos
nay the eyes have it motion is adopted
the house is in recess until Thursday
a.m.